وينضم الينا من الرياضه الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي محمد صالح الحربي مرحبا
واهلا بك استاذ محمد
بينما يروج له
الاوكرانيون مؤخرا ما بين الضغوط
البريطانيه على المانيا لتزويد اوكرانيا
بطائره برايها ستغير مجرى الحرب لصالح
الاوكرانيين بين الروس الذين يتحدثون ربما
عن خطه جديده همم في هجومهم العسكري على
الشرق الاوراني كيف ترى مشهد الحرب اليوم
هناك
مساء الخير تحيه لك والمشاهدين
الكرام نعرف انه هذا الحرب دائما وصفناها
منذ 24 فبراير بالحرب اللاتينيه اللا
تناظريه الغير تقليديه هناك حجم دعم غير
مسبوق من ضفتي الاطلسي وصل الى تقريبا
مليار يورو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
المانحه الاكبر تاتي بعدها في التسلسل
بريطانيا المانيا فرنسا الان نحن في 20 23
ربما هناك خطوط التماس او خطوط المواجهه
تثبت التقريبا الشرق اوكرانيا او شرق نهر
الجبهات الثلاثه التركيز عليها ولكن هناك
ما زالت قواعد الاشتباك منضبطه سيده
العزيزه ما بين
الاطلسي وروسيا روسيا ايضا اعلنت عن عقيده
اللي هتفعيل برنامج
استراتيجي وتغيير في العقيده الروسيه ايضا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دعمت هناك دعم غير متناهي للاسلحه ولكن
الفاعل والمجدي في هذه الفتره اللي هي
الاسلحه التكتيكيه طبعا هم بداوا في
البدايه بالصواريخ الفعاله اللي يا جافلين
سترينجر بوك او جراد حتى الروسيه في بدايه
المحروقه في مدايات قصيره الان بدات تتطور
المدايات كمدافع حادثه
مرضى او هارفي الدبابات الامريكيه وايضا
هناك ايضا لاحظنا خلال اسبوع الماضي ناقل
مجموعه الاي واكس 14 طائره من المانيا الى
القواعد في رومانيا ايضا نظام
الان سباق محمود في التسلق وهذه مرحله
ربما جديده ربما كله يريد ان يكسب اوراق
لمفاوضات مست
بالفعل ولكن هل نقرا من كل هذا الحرائق
العسكري والدبلوماسي وهذا الضغط من الجانب
الروسي ومن الجانب الاوكراني بانه مفاوضات
المستقبليه قد تكون قريبه يعني اليس من
مصلحه روسيا اليوم ايضا ان تكون المفاوضات
قريبه جدا اوكرانيا بالطبع من مصلحتها لان
هي من يتنفذ الهجوم او ما تتلقى الهجوم
على الارض ولكن روسيا ايضا تعاني داخليا
تعاني اقتصاديا هناك نقمه واسعه لا يتحدث
عنها الاعلام بشكل واضح هناك تعب في صفوف
همم جيشها وقوتها بعد الخسائر الكبيره
يعني هل لها مصلحه اليوم بان تطيل امد
الحرب همم لسنوات كما حصل في دول اخرى
وتحديد الدول العربيه
نقزاني بان ردا على سؤالك سيدتي العزيزه
نحنا نعرف انه التداعيات الاقتصاديه
العسكريه ولكن روسيا لا يمكن ان تتراجع
خطوه الى الوراء لانه هذا بمثابه انتحار
سياسي ضخت المليارات واجهه عقوبات قصوى
لامت متناهيه من ضفتي الاطلسي فانا اتوقع
انه كنا في البدايه نتكلم على الانتخابات
الامريكيه النصفيه انه الحب ربما ان تبدا
بالتلاصقه قبل همم نوفمبر 20 22 الان
سنتحدث ايضا عن الانتخابات الامريكيه 20
24 او نوفمبر 20 23 فالموضوع هو مت لازم
اقتصاديا ولكن في وجهه نظري الخاص طالما
اننا بدانا او تغطينا 11 شهر من هذه الحرب
منذ 24 اتوقع انه رؤوس يمكن انه لانه خطر
على القيادات الكبرى ان تتراجع او تنسحب
امام الراي العام الروسي وحيد وقرر يعتبر
التراجع او الانسحاب او الخضوع بمثابه
انتحار السياسي
للعصر السعوديه